the notion of accuracy and Trust are
problematic in a world of Photoshop and
tools like it where images like that
which is a composite race around the
world
after events and some are just made up
whole cloth to pretend some things are
happening and yes it was debunked and
yes it went that went around too but
probably there are still people who saw
that but who think it's real we have
ways of helping truth catch up with lies
but that's not enough
for all kinds of reasons if you want to
ask about that later glad to do it it's
not just people with Photoshop in their
classroom or basement or somewhere else
it's people at our best organizations
who profoundly screw up and in some
cases helps get Wars going so we have a
lot of work to do in traditional media
we need to improve the supply in every
way but I still trust more than not I've
been thinking about what to call some of
this and I that title there I've given
it as the disinformation political
technical industrial complex and it's a
little bit too long for a tweet but it
it feels like this is something we're
having to deal with now and the the
taxonomy here the Dana Boyd and her
folks that data and society did on
misinformation disinformation etc is
wonderful to look at and give you a lot
of guides the things that we're dealing
with are really troubling by the way I
don't like the expression fake news I
think we're stuck with it but I don't
like it for for really two reasons one
is I just I hate the idea that you put
fake next to news that feels wrong and
the other is that people who lie all the
time have taken it over and are using it
against people who don't lie all the
time so I would
prefer that we use words from the
taxonomy and and things like that but
it's really problematic
[Music]